there has been a series of papers that
have come out in the last year showing
how following a fasting mimicking diet
affected patients with Advanced cancers
and just last week early stages of
Alzheimer's
so in this video we will go through what
fmd's fasting and making diets are and
what these latest studies tell us
fasting when making diets otherwise
referred to as fmds are diets first
coined by Professor fotolongo which is
very much suggested by the name mimics
fasting while getting to eat food
sounds kind of non-logical but to cut a
very long story short there have been
many studies showing that periodic
fasting or dietary restriction
approaches has many benefits for
longevity such as increasing the
lifespan of mice and other muscle
organisms and a mice has been linked
with metabolic changes of many
health-related biomarkers such as blood
glucose anti-reactive protein levels
one of the reasons these fasting
mimicking diets were devised was to
mimic then this metabolic State achieved
during prolonged fasting while having a
diet that people can comply to and
doesn't put them at risk of
malnourishments
so what exactly does a fasting mimicking
diet until
well the diet is an intervention that a
patient takes once a month for five days
and consists of a low calorie low
protein diet but still provides all the
micronutrients necessary to avoid
malnutrition
so it includes items like plant-based
soups bars crackers and olives
the medically designed fasting the
making diets by prolon where Professor
Longo advises has set it up such that
the first day is around 1 100 calories
dropping to around 750 calories for days
two to five
however how can we trust this without
any human clinical trial data
well then let's move on to that
in terms of landmark papers fasting when
making diets were tested in healthy
human subjects and was shown to cause no
loss or an increase in lean body mass
and function
and reduced risk biomarkers for aging
diabetes cancer and cardiovascular
disease
skeletal muscle was also shown to be
retained in healthy Physically Active
men who underwent three cycles of a
fasting mimicking diodes
in this recent study they had 24 men 12
following the fasting mimicking diets
and 12 following a normal diet I took
measurements of force production before
after the first cycle and roughly a week
after the third cycle
while there was a significant decline in
body mass for those taking the fmd
after the first cycle Force production
muscle folium did not change
so at least in a small group of strength
athletes it seems feasible with no risk
of muscle loss
but what about testing fmd and patients
at risk of muscle loss such as
sarcopenia patients
and what about for other non-healthy
patients with diabetes cancer and
cardiovascular disease
well while clinical studies have not
been conducted for all of these diseases
yet data has been released within the
last year on cancer and Alzheimer's
disease which will examine for the
remainder of this video
so firstly this paper exceptional tumor
responses to fasting the making diets
combined with standard anti-cancer
Therapies
so before we jump into this paper it's
important to clarify a few things here
firstly what is meant by exceptional
tumor response I was usually cringe out
of paper if it said that their results
were exceptional so here they Define
exceptional tumor responses as patients
achieving complete and long-lasting
tumor emissions with cyclic fasting the
making diet in combination of
anti-cancer Therapies
so this trial was a monocentric open
label single arm perspective clinical
trial evaluating the safety feasibility
metabolic and immunomodulatory effects
of a cyclic fmd in patients with
different cancer types disease stages
and receiving different types of
Standards anti-neoplastic treatments
perfect mouthful so to reiterate it was
a trial that was open label so
participants and doctors knew what they
were doing and single arm meaning that
all the patients were following the
fasting and making diets and then they
were just followed over time to see how
these different biomarkers changed
and to save some time it is easiest for
me just to show you the highlights
whereby in total they present results
for five patients or with Advanced poor
prognosis solid neoplasms
so one patient had extensive stage small
cell lung cancer one had metastatic
pancreatic and then adenocarcinoma
one had the metastatic colorectal cancer
and two patients had metastatic triple
negative breast cancer
and so in all these cases they saw
exceptional tumor responses as I defined
earlier
and so it's kind of impossible to know
if the fasting mimicking diet really
added something here compared to
standard anti-cancer therapies since
this is a small study where five
patients actually presented here and
it's not like we have a control patient
who has exactly the same tumor type and
chemotherapy but without the fasting
they're making diets but that said the
impact of the fasting mimicking diet
appeared consistent despite the
different tumor types and included some
tumors that are currently very
challenging to treat such as pancreatic
cancer late stage breast cancer and
colorectal cancer
it would obviously also be nice to see
whether the fasting and making diets
alone is effective but at this stage the
gold standard is to still use standard
anti-cancer Therapies
so as written the results prompt the
initiation of clinical trials to
investigate cyclic fasting mimicking
diets in combination with standard
anti-tumotherapies in specific clinical
contacts
and then the most recent publication we
will finish with is involved with
treating outside Mr C's for which there
is currently still no cure and in
America is predicted to affect 13
million people by 2050.
so this is the paper fasting mimicking
diet Cycles reduce neuroinflammation to
attenuate cognitive decline in
Alzheimer's models so this is the map of
the paper and while it's more of an
interconnected web of experiments that
show exactly what the experimenters did
and to by and large the majority of this
paper is conducted in a series of mouse
experiments where they had two different
Mouse models of Alzheimer's disease and
I showed that by having these mice
followed the fighting mimicking diet it
showed a reduction in cognitive decline
based on a series of different
behavioral and memory tests and also a
reduction in Alzheimer's disease
pathology as you can see here the
decline in staining for amyloid beta in
the mice following the fasting they're
making diets
and so given these promising effects on
Mouse models they decided to test fastly
just the safety and feasibility of
fasting mimicking diet Cycles on
patients with amnestic modes cognitive
impairment or early stage Alzheimer's
disease
this troll in comparison to the cancer
one is a randomized and
placebo-controlled clinical study and so
they ended up with 12 following the
fasting mimicking diodes and 16
following the placebo
and in case you were wondering how you
would actually do a placebo in these
experiments the placebo diets assigned
to patients in the control arm consist
of replacing lunch or dinner with a meal
based on pasta or rice with vegetables
for five days a month
and so on average big groups did the
Cycles around six times and dropouts
were seen in both cases
but what we're seeing was that the
patient with mild cognitive impairments
following the fasting mimicking diet
intervention only my old symptoms were
observed including fatigue headaches
hypertension irritability and depression
but overall these initial data suggest
that a five-day fasting mimicking diet
cycle administered once a month have
been feasible and overall safe and a
small group of patients with early
Alzheimer's disease but we are still
awaiting cognitive assessments to see if
these Cycles actually slow down
cognitive decline or whether they can
reduce amyloid B to pathology in the
patients
so diet is important for health health
is the absence of disease these studies
then add to the conclusion that diet is
important for disease
whether that be for prevention or as we
have seen more in this video potentially
for treatment
arguably these studies are very small
and selective but fast in my making diet
is a natural intervention that seems
safe if followed correctly
and will be something I'll continue to
keep an eye on as more data comes out
in particular with the cancer study it
would be very interesting to understand
what's happening maybe to the immune
system and how this dieting response is
influencing the biochemistry of what's
going on is it linked autophagy or how
was these benefits being mediated
but with that I hope you learned
something in this video if you want to
catch an interview I did with photo
Longo last year then click here
otherwise thank you to my patreon
supporters
and thank you for listening